since you're italian
sicilian i also heard rumors that you
are a connoisseur of food
uh what you know if i said today is the
last day
you get to be alive i'm rushing you
shouldn't have trusted me
you never know the russian whether
you're gonna make it out or not well if
you had one last meal
you can travel somewhere in the world
either you make it or somebody else
makes it uh what's that gonna look like
all right if this is one last meal i
must say
hey you know invisi iraq coveted
hey i've not been able to see my mom
and uh and there was my mama was a
fantastic chef okay
and had the this very traditional food
as you know the very traditional food
are great for a reason
because they survived hundreds of years
of culinary innovation
yeah so and there is one very laborious
thing
which is uh and you heard the name which
is this uh
parmigiana but to do it it's a piece of
art
requires so many hours but only my mama
could do it if we have one last meal
i want to parmesan okay what is uh
what's what's the laborious process is
that the ingredients
is it the the actual process
is it the the atmosphere and the humans
involved
the latter a the ingredient like in any
other
in italian cuisine believes
in very few ingredients if you take
say quintessential italian recipe
everybody knows spaghetti pesto okay
pesto
is olive oil very good extra virgin oil
um a basil
pine nuts pepper a clove of garlic not
too much otherwise used
yeah you know everything and then you
have to
do either two schools of fort parmesan
or pecorino or a mixed number two
yeah i mentioned six ingredients yes
that is typical italian
that is i understand that there are
cuisines for instance a french cuisine
which is
extremely sophisticated and extremely
combinatorial
or some chinese cuisine which has a lot
of
many more ingredients and yet the artist
to put them together
a lot of things in italy is really
striving for simplicity
yet to find few ingredients but the
right ingredient is to create
something so in parmigiana the
ingredients are eggplants they are
tomatoes
we have basil but but how to put them
together
and the process he's uh he's an actor
of love okay or labor and love is that
uh you can spend uh the entire day
when i'm exaggerating by the entire
morning for sure to do it uh
properly yeah as a japanese cuisine too
there's a mastery to the simplicity
with the sushi i don't know if you've
seen george of sushi but there's a
mastery to that that's
propagated through the generations it's
fascinating
you